[Musique]
jeudi bouchon caméraman r
bonjour jacques attali où jouent et
merci de nous accorder cet entretien
vous êtes et ses listes économiste et
président de positive planète une
fondation qui vient en aide aux pays en
développement alors parlons de cette
europe dans cette crise sanitaire sans
précédent
la trouvez-vous à la hauteur comment
jugez-vous son action on a l'impression
que comme toujours elle est tiraillée
entre générosité et égoïsme mais c'est
ça mais comme parler de l'europe soit
trop de quoi vous parlez s'ils me parler
des européens en général il ya tout il
ya eu des actes de l'égoïsme de
fermeture de chacun pour soi
il ya il ya eu beaucoup de choses tout à
fait condamnable
mais en gros si on regarde bien il ya eu
aussi entre les entre les gens entre les
cités entre les entreprises beaucoup de
solidarité on a échangé des moyens où on
fait ce qu'on a pu et si on parle des
institutions parce que souvent quand on
parle d'europe on parle de l'union
européenne cette année à des
institutions
je trouve que pour l'instant ça aurait
pu être tout d'abord comment ça aurait
pu être pire parce qu on aurait pu
fermer les frontières entre les pays
européens juridiquement le pour
l'instant j'espère que ça va durer
schengen n'est pas annulée juridiquement
même si certaines frontières sont
évidemment beaucoup plus contrôlés sinon
fermez
les moyens de l'union européenne
continuent à fonctionner et et même
rompu dire que l'union européenne a fait
son travail à la banque centrale c'est
après quelques hésitations qui ont pas
durer 24 heures il me l'a fait et moyens
de la banque centrale seront
considérables
le les gouvernements européens ont mis
sur la table petits montants parce qu'on
dit 500 milliards mais c'est pas vrai
parce qu'il ya trois sanctions pas
vraiment utiliser apparition trop
conditionnelle mais c'est pas suffisant
mais bon ils sont pas utilisables et
ensuite c'est pas clairement quelque
chose de
deux
correspondants allemands jouent de la
crise en fait la banque centrale et
j'ajoute avant de revenir sur votre
question comment fait l'union européenne
n'a pas de compétence en matière de
santé donc faut pas s'étonner qu'il
n'occupe pas puisque c'est pas dans un
domaine de compétence mais pour autant
il semble
aujourd'hui la clé de ce qui est en
train de se dérouler c'est de savoir si
les pays européens
indépendants individuellement leurs
entreprises leurs citoyens et l'union
européenne dans son ensemble à être
capable de passer la deuxième étape de
la crise économique et politique c'est à
dire de donner du sens à tout ça et de
créer les conditions de la
du redémarrage des entreprises qui sont
pour l'instant mise en état de perfusion
alors qu'elle pourrait être le sens
donné au 27 pour le nom d'après
l'épidémie vous parlez de l'économie de
la vie est ce qu'elle doit être prise en
charge au niveau de jeu haché que nous
et en particulier au niveau de l'union
européenne et pour masquer le monde
apprécie le nom de tout de suite c'est
maintenant que ça commence quand on se
réfère par exemple à l'exemple ce qui
s'est passé pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale en france parce qu'on était des
collabos essentielle donnée mais même
les résistants ont travaillé pendant le
vulgaire à la préparation du programme
de l'après donc la presse commence
maintenant et la presse et la prise de
conscience de ce qu'il ya des secteurs
qui ont été négligés sous-estimé temps
terminus
rémunération de ceux qui travaillent en
termes de moyens financiers on y
consacre qui sont ce que la peine
l'économie de la vie qui ne représente
aujourd'hui dans nos pays qu'entre
45 et 50 % des travailleurs et soit 60 à
65 70 pensantes du pilote sait c'est une
secteur
devrait représenter beaucoup plus à la
casse ont alors quelles sont ces
secteurs qui ont construit d'abord la
santé l'hygiène les déchets l'énergie
propre la protection de l'environnement
l'éducation la recherche
le digital la distribution les grands
d'après tructures le logement la
sécurité les éléments de la démocratie
éléments d'information et les éléments
de la culture voilà dix secteurs et dans
ces secteurs que faudrait-il faire il
faudrait les sortir de toute musique
budgétaire investir massivement d'abord
il faudrait investir massivement comme
dans une déco big air et investir
massivement ses créateurs du croissance
si les entreprises qui produisent
aujourd'hui des automobiles ou qui ne
produisent pas doué parce que qui va
acheter une auto naveen aujourd'hui ou
dans les mois qui viennent ou des avions
été mise maintenant à produire les
masques les respirateurs les hôpitaux et
à trouver des réponses aux enjeux d'une
économie distancié qui va être durable
d'abord ça leur donnerait du travail ça
crée une émulation chez des ingénieurs
des techniciens qui aujourd'hui se
croisent les doigts les prêts alors que
vous pourrez faire beaucoup
et ça motive ça donnerait un sens à ce
que l'économie européenne c'est
d'ailleurs assez ironique de dire qu'on
va se mettre en économie de guerre pour
développer une économie de la vie des
économies de la vie devrait représenter
une part beaucoup plus importante de
notre richesse et elle donne du sens
parce que l'économie de la vie ça donne
vraiment ça renvoie à ce que nous
affichons aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
affiche au long dur la fiche que la vie
est plus importante que l'économie
puisse comme ami mais concrètement
comment elle pourrait se mettre en
oeuvre on redéploie complètement nos
politiques publiques on donne plus de
moyens certains secteurs au détriment
d'autres d'abord ça dépend beaucoup des
entreprises elles mêmes et de chacun de
nous plutôt que se croiser les bras et
attendre
on pourrait dès maintenant dans les
entreprises certains le sont
produire plus dense et c'est que même si
on n'y est pas nous convertir en fait
les les productions industrielles
renault devrait fabriquer des masques
mais renault c'est scandaleux que renaud
veeckman masque si scandaleux que
renault ne fabrique pas le respirateur
et que s'ils sont des choses ils le sont
douces pour ne pas à montrer qu'ils font
quelque chose mais nous on reproduit le
match de façon visible
c'est un vrai changement vous avez des
chiffres
important vous dites il faut tout de
suite si on veut réussir le déconfite
mans produire un milliard de masques par
mois ça c'est pour la france deux
millions de tests rien que pour la
france en un mois on en a marre on ne
pas dépendre n'importe l'importation de
plantation sporadiques et à certaines
venant d'europe ça fait longtemps que je
dis que l'europe ça ne peut pas se
réduire à une politique de concurrence
de voir la routine politique
industrielle c'est l'occasion d'avoir
avec du sang mais est-ce qu'on peut y
aller oui si près du stade n'en rater de
ce type si on met en place comme
non pas des 'eurobonds' à la cantonade
mais des
remblais l'iphone se
sait tout se précise c'est tout
messianisme de dette non aux mutualistes
des avis très centre mutualisé des
investissements futurs dans les secteurs
en question et ont créé un fonds de 1000
milliards comprendre un chiffre qui a du
sens qui financerait les initiatives
européennes dans ces secteurs ce faux
redonnerait à toutes les entreprises de
ces secteurs mais aussi aux entreprises
des autres secteurs qui pourrait se
reconvertir
on produira moins d'avions pour les
années qui viennent mais l'industrie les
compétences incroyable les ingénieurs
d'airbus et toutes les entreprises sous
traitant d'airbus doivent être mises à
contribution
moi ça fait extrêmement longtemps que je
dis que l'industrie de la santé est un
secteur majeur que nous avons totalement
négligé
c'est l'occasion il développer les
industries de la santé tant que vous
dites économiques de la vie on réoriente
complètement la production et les
investissements au niveau européen comme
au niveau de notre pays et on le fait
dès maintenant l'europe dans ces
secteurs là elle a une longueur d'avancé
est ce qu'elle peut plus que la chine
par exemple faire de cette crise une
chance une chute ou ces secteurs là
sauter place et du monde
l'alimentation est pas pu le dire
l'hygiène si la chine avait la
méridienne que nous on n'en serait pas
là aujourd'hui en terme de crise
l'éducation aussi le seul secteur moins
en apparence moins bien ces digital mais
c'est pas vrai parce que nous avons
beaucoup d'entreprises digitale de très
haut niveau qui sont capables
aujourd'hui de donner un coup de collier
participer à cela on le voit pas
beaucoup d'initiatives qui apparaissent
est extrêmement prometteuse alors
pourquoi pourquoi ne pas tout de suite
puisque vous parler d'économie de la vie
à l'échelle européenne sur le main
centré sur le soin sur l'autre
l'altruisme pourquoi ne pas basculer
d'entrée de jeu les politiques de santé
au niveau fédéral et pas seulement les
politiques grussaute et c'est pour ça
que je dis la santé n'est qu'un des dix
secteurs de l'économie la vie il faut il
faut il mettre tous les autres pour que
ce soit donc ce soit cohérent pourquoi
est ressentie comme une fois beaucoup
plus d'intégration européenne
loloum parce que c'est il faut que ce
soit une idéologie commune il faut que
ça soit pour que l'idée de l'économie de
la vie soit soit appliquée voulu dans
une petite ville de l'est afghan dans
une entreprise de dix salariés dans une
chaîne de télévision comme la vôtre donc
c'est la société tout entière que vos
défenses écart jamais balancé la cité
qui doit prendre conscience que on n'est
plus dans l'économie du futile mais
qu'on est dans l'économie on n'est pas
non plus dans l'économie de la survie
mais on est dans l'économie de la vie
être intéressé à au bien-être d'autrui à
la chine qui en tous les cas tient ce
discours aussi en ce moment nous ne
serons pas capables
de nous sortir de cette histoire
indépendant d'un pays qui n'est pas une
démocratie
qui est à l'origine du problème et qui
nous donne quelques moyens parfaitement
recevable mais qui ne doit pas nous les
donner sous
condition d'accepter sa domination
idéologique qu'elle n'a pas donné encore
quand les vois le gars si médiatisé
habilement sa générosité vous dites
attention naulleau nos jeux dignes et
sur le prochain iphone la chine est un
partenaire respectable et respecté qui
font respecter comme partenaire mais on
ne peut pas dans l'économie la vie
dépend de partenaires quel qu'il soit ni
des etats unis c'est aujourd'hui dans la
pierre des bandas déni de la chine qui
est à l'origine du problème il faut
qu'on
l'accès petit partenaire sérieux mais
seulement du partenaire vous ne traînez
pas le repli sur soi le tour des nations
et des frontières dont on voit bien que
je suis sont au centre du débat ce que
je crains on peut dans deux ans nous
plus avoir d'union européenne ont peu à
peu je peux vous faire le scénario de la
défaisance de l'union européenne parce
qu'elle n'aura pas été capable de faire
tout ce qu'on vient dire maintenant mais
il faut pour éviter que ça ait lieu
défini un projet pour moi c'est l'europe
de la vitre et le projet est pas
l'europe de la sueur aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans l'europe de la survie et
c'est une erreur considérable que nous
rester là cette émission s'appelle le
jour d'après vous pensez qu'il faut
comme ça nourrir peut-être même un
imaginaire
après après l'épidémie après le
confinement au contraire vous méfier de
ceux qui disent que rien ne sera plus
comme avant
les de la fois je me méfie ceux qui
disent que rien ne soit plus comme avant
mais je me méfie de ceux qui ne parlent
que du jour d'après parce que pour moi
le jour d'après commence maintenant
merci beaucoup jacques attali d'avoir
accepté cet entretien à bientôt
[Musique]